all right so now we know how to parse
JSON data how do we actually retrieve
that from our server this is where XML
HTTP requests come in an XML HTTP
request allows our JavaScript code
running in a browser to fire a request
off to our server to a specific URL we
can also specify a function to call once
the server responds to our request now
there are a few steps to this first we
need to create a new xml httprequest
object and we do this using the new
keyword followed by xml httprequest with
the parentheses now note that case is
sensitive here next we need to call the
XML HTTP requests open method first we
need to specify the HTTP method to use
in our cases we're pretty much always
going to want to use get second we
specify the URL to call out to for
example if we were requesting a JSON
file we would specify the file name that
we are interested in finally we specify
a boolean value that is set to true if
we want the call to be asynchronous we
pretty much always want the call to be
asynchronous next we specify the onload
parameter which is a function that we
define that gets called once the server
responds to our request finally we need
to call the xhr s send method this will
actually kick off the request note that
we need to do all of these things first
before we can call send otherwise the
requests might hit the server and
respond before we can specify our onload
function and if that happens we won't
actually know what to do with the
response yet